Let us now conclude with a fun
problem, which is also a
little bit of a puzzle.
We are told that the
king comes from a
family of two children.
What is the probability that
his sibling is female?
Well, the problem is too loosely
stated, so we need to
start by making some
assumptions.
First, let's assume that we're
dealing with an anachronistic
kingdom where boys
have precedence.
In other words, if the royal
family has two children, one
of which is a boy and one is a
girl, it is always the boy who
becomes king, even if the
girl was born first.
Let us also assume that when
a child is born, it has 50%
probability of being
a boy and 50%
probability of being a girl.
And in addition, let's assume
that different children are
independent as far as their
gender is concerned.
Given these assumptions,
perhaps we
can argue as follows.
The king's sibling is
a child which is
independent from the king.
Its gender is independent from
the king's gender, so it's
going to be a girl with
probability 1/2.
And so this is one possible
answer to this problem.
Is this a correct answer?
Well, let's see.
We have to make a more precise
model, so let's
go ahead with it.
We have two children, so there
are four possible outcomes--
boy, boy; boy, girl; girl,
boy; and girl, girl.
Each one of these outcomes has
probability 1/4 according to
our assumptions.
For example, the probability of
a boy followed by a boy is
1/2 times 1/2, where we're
also using independence.
So each one of these four
outcomes has the same
probability, 1/4.
Now, we know that there is a
king, so there must be at
least one boy.
Given this information, one
of the outcomes becomes
impossible, namely the
outcome girl, girl.
And we're restricted to a
smaller universe with only
three possible outcomes.
Our new universe is this green
universe, which includes all
outcomes that have at least
one boy, so that
we can get a king.
We should, therefore, use the
conditional probabilities that
are appropriate to this
new universe.
Since these three outcomes
inside the green set have
equal unconditional
probabilities, they should
also have equal conditional
probabilities.
So each one of these three
outcomes should have a
conditional probability
equal to 1/3.
In two of these outcomes the
sibling is a girl and
therefore, the conditional
probability given that there
is a king and therefore given
that there is a boy, the
conditional probability
is going to be 2/3.
So this is actually the official
answer to this
problem, and this answer
is incorrect.
Are we satisfied with
this answer?
Maybe yes, maybe no.
Actually, some more assumptions
are needed in
order to say that 2/3 is
the correct answer.
Let me state what these
assumptions are.
We assume that the royal family
decided to have exactly
two children.
So the number two that we
have here is not random.
It was something that
was predetermined.
Once they decided to have the
two children, they had them.
At least one turned out
to be a boy and that
boy became a king.
Under this situation, indeed,
the probability that the
sibling of the king
is female is 2/3.
But these assumptions that I
just stated are not the only
possible ones.
Let's consider some alternative
assumptions.
For example, suppose
that the royal
family operated as follows.
They decided to have children
until they get one boy.
What does this tell us?
Well, since they had two
children, this tells us
something--
that the first child
was a girl.
So in this case, the probability
that the king's
sibling is a girl
is equal to 1.
The only reason why they had two
children was because the
first was a girl and then
the second was a boy.
Suppose that the royal family
made some different choices.
They decided to have children
until they would get two boys,
just to be sure that the line
of succession was secured.
In this case, if we are told
that there are only two
children, this means that there
were exactly two boys,
because if one of the two
children was a girl, the royal
family would have continued.
So in this particular case,
the probability that the
sibling is a girl is
equal to zero.
And you can think of other
scenarios, as well, that might
give you different answers.
So 2/3 is the official answer,
as long as we make the precise
assumptions that the number of
children, the number two, was
predetermined before anything
else happened.
The general moral from this
story is that when we deal
with situations that are
described in words somewhat
vaguely, we must be very careful
to state whatever
assumptions are being made.
And that needs to be done before
we are able to fix a
particular probabilistic
model.
This process of modeling will
always be something of an art
in which judgment calls
will have to be made.